I think if I would if I tried to narrow
it down to its essence it would be the
entrepreneur themselves you know very
rarely does a business or never does a
business plan come true you have to be
flexible you have to work your way
through the challenges learn what's
going on and I think if the personality
of the leader is one that's open to new
ideas response to a market quickly that
they'll figure it out I think that the
greatest trap is really when you're
fixed on your idea and believe it has to
stay exactly the way it is to be
successful that's that's pretty
dangerous
well I'd say that's half of it I'd say
equally important is the fact that they
run out of money they constantly
underestimate the amount of capital they
need and they constantly are in a
position where they're spending their
time trying to raise the next payroll
when in reality they should be building
a business
I'd say those two are pretty good